[Music]
on this Sunday night getting Canadians
out of China a second evacuation flight
is scheduled but not everyone is allowed
on got the confirmation and then they
said no to me
the confusion in Wuhan as coronavirus
spreads pipeline protests the blockades
hurting business in Canada plus the
investigation into a former Canadian
reservists accused of trying to spark a
race revolution and consumer controversy
their data is being used really to
create profitable products the company
that's turning DNA into drugs
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us it's the news more than 150 Canadians
have been waiting days to hear they can
finally go home thousands of people
including 36 Canadians have disembarked
the world dream cruise ship they were
stuck on the vessel for four days
because of concerns over the new
coronavirus but they're back on solid
ground today and appear to be in good
spirits after all tests for the deadly
virus came back negative meanwhile
Ottawa has chartered a second flight to
bring more Canadians home from Wuhan
China the passenger list is still being
compiled but the government expects the
manifest to be finalized in the next few
hours the plane should take off tomorrow
but as Michael Couture explains there's
confusion about who will be allowed to
board they clarified that I'm not on the
list and which means I'm not allowed to
leave yiqiang is stuck in Wuhan China
the Torontonian has permanent resident
status in Canada but was in China for
business when the corona virus outbreak
hit and he says Global Affairs Canada
told him he can't get on the next
evacuation flight back home they just
told me they understand my situation and
then I'm not a priority right now I was
wrong about create a citizen Canadian
now said there were about a dozen
permanent residents on the first
evacuation flight but it's believed they
were allowed on because they were
accompanying children Thursday Foreign
Affairs Minister Francois Philip
champaing said the government is trying
to get everyone out of China we're
certainly pushing to to include also
permanent residents who could be coming
back home and we will continue to make
that representation to China but there's
confusion because people in Wuhan are
being told it's the Canadian government
not the Chinese who's saying permanent
residents can't leave so while the
second government Charter to repatriate
Canadians has left CFB Trenton
it would seem Jang won't be on that
plane ride back home coronavirus has
already claimed more than 800 lives in
less than two months that surpasses the
number of SARS victims over an eight
month period back in 2003 despite that
the
Prime Minister says the risk remains low
in Canada the measures that we are we
have taken on as recommended by the
World Health Organization and our own
chief medical officer are effective till
now some of those measures include
putting two hundred and thirteen people
in florentine at CFB Trenton and today
we got our first glimpse of life on the
base which includes fresh air time for
evacuees if in talking to friends from
distance well at least 2 meters I guess
and it's good for have a break and it
was a good break for Canadians were
among the crew and passengers of a
cruise ship that had been quarantined
for four days in Hong Kong amid fears
some staff contracted the virus on a
previous voyage most were relieved to be
let off but this man felt otherwise
life on the shore isn't actually too
comforting he says echoing fears shared
by some in that part of the world as the
virus continues to spread Michel
accretor Global News Ottawa Canada's
Foreign Affairs Minister Francois
Philippe champagne is calling on Iran to
release the black boxes from the
Ukrainian plane that was shot down last
month by Iran's Revolutionary Guard
chompin says the flight data recorders
need to be analyzed outside of Iran
noting it's been more than a month since
a hundred and seventy-six people died in
the downing of flight 75 2 including 57
Canadians jump on made the comments in
Ethiopia's capital where he's travelling
with the Prime Minister
there comes a time where you need to
come to terms and say you know what I
think they've understood from the
different Civil Aviation Authority in
the world that the type of equipment and
expertise you need to read the block's
box cannot be brought to Iran so the
solution in front of all of us whether
it's the world community on the
international response and coordination
group is to send these black boxes
without delay to Paris which has all the
equipment the minister also says Iran's
government has appointed someone to
begin negotiations to pay state
compensation to the families of the
victims
demonstrators across the country are
demanding an end to the arrests of
indigenous activists at a protest site
in northern BC members of the wetsuit
nation want to stop the construction of
the coastal gas lake pipeline through
ancestral territory which they say isn't
subject to any treaty agreements as
Kathryn Hart reports the issue is
spilling over into other parts of BC and
across the country for the fourth day
protestors blocked entrances to the Port
of Vancouver Canada's largest port and
the Gateway for trade to the rest of the
world are you willing to be arrested
yeah I definitely am I think that
legality doesn't necessarily mean
morality the Port Authority says the
protests are impacting operations
significantly it's the same story at
Delta port just south of Vancouver where
a blockade is stalling business at
Canada's flagship Container Terminal we
do understand that there is a sense of
urgency in this matter and really we're
there to help facilitate a peaceful
resolution the protests are spilling
over from a month-long dispute involving
the wet sweat nation they oppose a six
billion dollar natural gas pipeline
project the 670 kilometre pipeline is
intended to carry gas from northeastern
BC to a massive LNG export plant being
built near Kitimat coastal gas link says
it has signed agreements with the
elected councils of all 20 First Nations
along the path of the pipeline including
the wet sweatin
but the hereditary Chiefs aren't on side
it's illegal what they're doing everyone
that they arrested removed from our
territory were never charged it's just
harassment and they were not impeding
any access at all they were in the homes
the RCMP have been enforcing a BC
Supreme Court injunction to remove
activists since Thursday Mounties have
been advancing down a forest service
road along the way dismantling
protesters camps to allow the work to
begin so far 21 people have been
arrested in BC's capital there are
demonstrations of support for the West
sweatin protesters lit a ceremonial fire
at the provincial legislature across the
country in Toronto pipeline opponents
blocked a rail line causing freight and
passenger train delays anything we can
do that can be done in support will
happen back in Vancouver the protests go
on there isn't a court injunction to get
rid of them and there's no indication
that Vancouver police will step in like
the Mounties have up north catheter cart
Global News Vancouver Thai commandos
shot dead a rogue soldier who killed 29
people in Thailand's worst mass shooting
police say the 32 your gunman was killed
this morning a few hours after they
raided a busy shopping mall where he'd
been holed up the attack started
yesterday afternoon at a military base
before the shooter moved on to the
shopping center he posted messages to
social media as he went at one point the
Thai military brought in his mother to
try to negotiate with him investigators
believe the soldier was angry over a
financial dispute Democratic
presidential candidates are in a race
against the clock ahead of the New
Hampshire primary on Tuesday senator
Bernie Sanders maintains a lead heading
into the vote but attacks from all
candidates are squarely focused on PTI
judge who has seen a surge in support
following his narrow victory in Iowa
Reggie Cecchini reports Democratic
presidential hopefuls Criss crossing the
Granite State trying to lock in support
and court undecided voters are the other
candidates good yes yes
some of them are but there's too many of
them that's the problem
former Vice President Joe Biden
maintains a lead nationally but senator
Bernie Sanders remains the fan favorite
in New Hampshire and while the two
candidates have different policy views
they're both on the same side when it
comes to a rising star from the Midwest
Barack Obama called Joe Biden Biden
launching a grenade into Pete Buddha
judges campaign mocking the former
Indiana mayor's experience under threat
of a nuclear Iran Jill Biden helped to
negotiate the Iran deal and under threat
of disappearing pets Buddha judge
negotiated later licensing regulations
the former VP reminding Buddha judge
what VP stands for but he's talking from
the beginning about how I don't have a
record to run on me as if I wasn't any
part of that administration but the
criticism against Biden also comes from
the public his poll numbers are falling
and he failed to break the top three in
Iowa meanwhile Sanders whose grassroots
movement has flooded him with support is
attacking Buddha judges donor lists he
has about 40 billionaires who are
contributing to his campaign Buddha
judge saying inclusion beats out
isolation we've gotten two million
contributions in this campaign I think
the average is under forty bucks and we
are building the movement that is going
to defeat Donald Trump I want everybody
to help out historically no presidential
candidate has finished lower than second
place in New Hampshire and gone on to
win the nomination
putting pressure on campaigns to get out
the vote I know you and I will fight for
you New Hampshire it's going to be up to
you with a pool of voters still
candidate shopping Democrats have to
walk a fine line appealing to a base on
both policy and that ability to be
Donald Trump Robin
Reggie Cecchini in Washington Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau says he has
pressed Egypt's leader on Canadian
citizens detained in that country the
two leaders sat down this weekend in
Ethiopia at a summit of African leaders
a year ago Egyptian authorities arrested
Canadian engineer Yasser Alba's as he
was leaving Cairo they've held him
without any public charges Trudeau says
promoting human rights is a key priority
on his trip to Africa he's
seeking support for Canada to get a seat
on the United Nations Security Council
as David Icke and reports from Ethiopia
tonight
Trudeau's government is winning praise
for helping female entrepreneurs in
developing countries a traditional
welcome ceremony for Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau to talk about a welcomed
initiative here in Africa and other
parts of the developing world helping
women start up their own businesses when
women and girls have access to education
and jobs they lift their communities up
but all too often they're still missing
out on those opportunities moving
forward together towards greater
prosperity means ensuring that no one
gets left behind
this is Africa and the Equality of women
and men steam is not classified like the
other countries Canada is often
criticized for not spending enough on
foreign aid it only spends about 6
billion dollars a year or 0.28 percent
of GDP but Canada does get credit for
how it spends that money with a focus on
helping women and girls in developing
countries around the world
sometimes that Aid goes to improve
maternal and child health but an
increasing amount of Canada's foreign
aid budget is now spent helping female
entrepreneurs get access to financing
and training to start and run their own
business as a government seeing some
real results one of the challenges of
getting women to be entrepreneurs has
always been there and we're beginning to
see that success but the other challenge
is always to get entrepreneurs in Canada
to see global markets
as that possibility it's an approach
that has the full support of the
business owners Trudeau met on Sunday I
mean it is fantastic because especially
you know on that level when there is a
supportive woman it can trickle down and
it is very important for such kind of a
support because this is what makes the
woman case stronger and it's a foreign
aid focus it could have a payoff back in
Canada reals business is now so
successful she is exporting her product
it's a traditional Ethiopian flatbread
called injera she is exporting that the
customers in Toronto Robin David Aiken
reporting tonight coming up the FBI
investigation into the former Canadian
reservists tied to a neo-nazi group
a former Canadian Forces reservists from
Winnipeg could face up to 60 years in
prison after being indicted by a u.s.
grand jury
Patrick Mathews was arrested as part of
a sweep against an American neo-nazi
group that was allegedly plotting to
incite violence at a gun rally in
Virginia as Eric Sorenson reports were
learning more about what's behind the
chilling accusations in one sense these
are the moderates gun rights advocates
with their high-powered weapons rallying
peacefully in Virginia last month
despite the rhetoric little did people
here realize the violence that might
have happened
according to the FBI some members of the
base a white supremacist group spoke of
targeting people at this rally the FBI
says the base wants to start a race war
in the u.s. that would lead to a white
ethno State this is a group that is
proponents of terror attacks Ryan for
pan' investigative reporter for the
Winnipeg Free Press and got to know a
Canadian connected to the base
Patrick Matthews last August shortly
after Thorpe published a story about him
and the base the RCMP raided Matthews
home and seized weapons a week later
Matthews was reported missing soon he
would be on the radar of the FBI he
walked into a pretty elaborate FBI
investigation and actually interacted
with an undercover agent within two days
of being reported missing in Manitoba
the FBI says Matthews crossed the US
border illegally and made his way to
Michigan there he met two men who had
driven up from Maryland members of the
base a group already being closely
watched by the FBI the trio then drove
back to Maryland and Matthews was taken
to Virginia two weeks later one of the
men Mark Laemmle drove Matthews in a
pickup truck down to Georgia there were
other members of the base there oh and
one other key figure an FBI agent who
had infiltrated the Georgia group the
FBI says Matthews bought a mole and
there was a training camp like this one
with guns in November Matthews returned
north to an apartment in Delaware in
December the FBI snuck in installed a
camera and seized images of Matthews
testing out a gas
and other evidence the FBI says it heard
Matthews in Laemmle talk about inciting
violence at the upcoming gun rally in
Richmond Virginia in January On January
1st the FBI observed Matthews and
Laemmle exiting a store in Delaware
where they bought ammunition they would
buy fifteen hundred rounds a week later
the FBI says the two were imagining
violence at the Virginia rally quoting
Matthews there is just angry gun owners
just streaming in from all over the
country and Laemmle later saying they're
like shooting their way out of the city
essentially finally on January the 16th
the FBI moved in and arrested Laemmle
and Matthews four days before the gun
rally in Richmond the rally went off
without incident days later Matthews now
with long hair and others were indicted
on multiple weapons offenses they took
steps to act and act violently on their
racist views in order to spark what he
called a violent revolution for the
white race Matthews lawyer called his
statements free speech mr. Matthews
statements should be considered in the
context of in exercising his First
Amendment rights the arrests broke up
one plot but Ryan Thorp says the base as
a disparate group of cells remains
dangerous there's indication they had
every intention of carrying out violence
on people and I don't think we should be
cavalier about the level of violence
that could have perpetrated had law
enforcement not acted and remember the
trio down in Georgia with an FBI agent
on the inside they were arrested - and
there was one more twist the FBI says
one of them got worried about Matthews
believing he was a threat to their
broader operation and spoke of killing
him in the end the FBI not only may have
prevented violence at the gun rally they
may have saved Patrick Matthews life
Erik Sorensen Global News Toronto still
ahead the rocky airplane landing that
will have you on the edge of yours
seat
a powerful storm is battering Britain
with hurricane-force winds and so much
rain that more than 200 flood warnings
are in place across the UK
rushing water ripped through the streets
of this town in Yorkshire and it's a
similar scene in many other places train
travel has been brought to a halt by
floodwaters and high winds and just
imagine being a passenger on this plane
as it tried to land in those punishing
winds the storm forced a flight from
Warsaw to London to divert to Birmingham
where it touched down swerving side to
side and then landed with a bounce the
storm has caused hundreds of flight
delays and cancellations in the UK and
across Europe there is political turmoil
in Ireland an exit poll suggests a dead
heat after yesterday's parliamentary
elections ballot counting is still under
way but the poll indicates the Prime
Minister centrist finna Gale party is
neck-and-neck with the opposition Fionna
fall and a third party Shin feign all
three parties have received about 22% of
first preference votes analysts are
forecasting some sort of coalition is
inevitable up next a DNA testing company
faces ethical questions after developing
a new drug
you
a new development in the DNA analysis
business has stirred controversy one of
the leading companies in the field has
helped create a new drug using samples
collected from its own clients but as
Ross Lord reports it raises questions
about what those swabs of saliva are
really being used for and whether
customers are getting a fair deal
for the DNA testing company 23andme
converting customers genetic information
into a pharmaceutical drug is a big
breakthrough after years of research the
company has sold its first compound to
Spanish drug maker al morale it's an
antibody designed to prevent skin
inflammation like psoriasis in a
statement 23andme says working with Al
morale we're pleased to be furthering
23andme mission of helping people
benefit from genetic insights but any
financial benefits will stay with a drug
company not customers an arrangement
some bioethicists questioned those
people should be able to share in the
profits they're not necessarily as aware
as subjects are in a research trial that
their data is being used really to
create profitable products it's a new
frontier for an industry founded on
deepening our understanding of ancestry
and providing insight on predispositions
to specific health issues roughly 10
million people around the world have
paid 23andme to analyze their DNA about
80 percent of customers have agreed
their anonymous information can be used
for drug research and that the agreement
comes with no financial benefit but now
that it's becoming a reality
some might reconsider the arrangement a
lot of people are going to start to
question their participation in those
services in Canada a 23andme ancestry
kit costs $129 but if you want to use
their medical testing services - that
increases to 249 dollars they're going
to start to doubt that these services
are worth their investment indeed
23andme is now announcing sales have
declined the company is laying off staff
and scaling back its clinical studies
division a surprising turn in the
unpredictable world of DNA collection
the rise in popularity over the last few
years Ross Lord global news and that is
global national for this Sunday I'm
Robin Gill tonight your Canada is gone
to the point in New Brunswick thank you
for watching
Donna freeze and we'll be here tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
you